a moment of relief for Teresa May the
British Prime Minister has delivered
against the odds after nearly two years
of negotiations May and the EU have
agreed on the terms of their divorce she
took the opportunity to remind critics
of her conviction there were those who
said that reaching a brexit agreement
that worked for both sides was an
impossible task from the start I
rejected that council of despair and set
about negotiating a deal that worked for
the UK and the EU one that delivered on
the result of the referendum and set us
on course for a prosperous future while
maintaining a close relationship with
our friends and neighbors but her
victory could be short-lived May must
now sell the plan to a divided British
Parliament so far she doesn't have a
majority to pass it and some MPs from
her own party have vowed to vote against
it the European Union has warned
rebellious lawmakers in Westminster that
there is no other alternative I'm
inviting those who have to ratify this
deal in the House of Commons to take
this in consideration this is the best
deal possible for Britain this is the
best impossible for Europe this is the
only the only deal possible may now
faces a maker break vote that will again
test her resilience she will tour the UK
in a charm offensive aimed at getting
support for her deal with Brussels the
British people don't want to spend any
more time arguing about brexit they want
a good deal done that fulfils the boat
and allows us to come together again as
a country so I will take this deal back
to the House of Commons confident we
have achieved the best deal available
and full of optimism about the future of
our country in Parliament and Beyond it
I will make the case for this deal with
all my heart and I look forward to that
campaign
today the European Council endorsed the
agreement on the withdrawal of the
United Kingdom of Great Britain and
Northern Ireland from the European Union
and the European atomic energy community
on this basis the European Council
invited the Commission the European
Parliament and the council to take the
necessary steps to ensure that the
agreement can enter into force on the
30th of March 2019 so as to provide for
an orderly who is wrong diplomatic work
of art has been accomplished in an
extremely difficult situation an
unprecedented situation something we
have never had to face until now a
country leaving the European Union
having to create a contractual exit
agreement taking into account the
different interests but also at the same
time looking towards the future a future
that allows a close partnership which
will likely mean tough negotiations but
also a future where we always wish each
other success and our agreement was the
only way that this was possible unity
none none or norovirus consumer clear
let me now draw indeed abuse
correspondent Barbara basil in London
Barbara given the opposition to resume
phases in getting a break the deal
through Parliament does she have reason
to be optimistic about the outcome not
really not as we stand here now because
she is really surrounded by opponents
when she was in Brussels she tried to
convey a sense of optimism in the in the
sense that let's move on people we've
had this discussion now and we shall
open a new chapter and we shall look to
the future in in a sense of optimism and
an expectation but if you look at social
media here people get quite angry about
that channeling that Prime Minister now
this is the most important decision for
Britain within a couple of generations
you can tell us just to sort of wipe
this off the table move on accept what's
there and then just carry on was our
particularly as economists are now
predicting that people in Britain might
be poorer even after the breaks a deal
that has been put on the table by
Brussels so she is having an uphill
struggle all the way and the EU
Commission President jean-claude Juncker
insists there will be no negotiations on
the brakes indeed saying as we heard now
report this is the only deal possible
so our Britain's really facing the
choice between this deal or no deal as
far as Brussels is concerned I'm
reaching yes however do the politicians
in London who are not in favor of it
want to listen the answer is a clear no
even conservative MPs have this morning
been doing the rounds of radio studios
here in London and talking to everybody
and saying now listen we want something
else we don't like this we want
something more like Norway there must be
other options we could remain in the
single market we could do this or the
other so for them that chapter doesn't
seem to be closed they simply don't want
to accept this deal whatever brussels
says so for theresa made this is
difficult what she is going to do as she
is really under time constraint because
she needs to talk to Parliament this
afternoon and answer urgent questions it
will be the same as we have seen in the
past then she needs to go to Argentina
and participate in the g20 summit and
after that it just leaves her a week to
make a tour of Great Britain to go to
Wales Scotland another at Northern
Ireland where people are particularly
angry about the deal for different
reasons and try to convince them so in
the end what we see here that in Britain
the battle for brexit is far from over
and further turbulence is ahead bob
reversal in london thank you very much
for the analysis